for another month into the fall season
of 2015 and the barrage of great games
hasn't slowed down October housed a
diverse array of stellar titles from
hand-drawn Norse adventures too
unforgiving platformers it was also a
great month for expansions set a project
read released the first major addition
to its masterful RPG the witcher 3 wild
hunt giving us a variety of new quests
to tackle in hearts of stone meanwhile
for access games completely reimagine
several facets of its sci fi strategy
game with civilization beyond Earth
rising tide in this expansion you
establish floating cities that can move
substantially changing the way you can
play down well on the other hand
exemplified focused design there are
only three buttons and one clear
objective get to the bottom of a
randomly generated vertical drop despite
its simplicity we take hours into this
difficult scroller acquiring new
abilities and besting our old scores
then there was jotun a game with a
hand-sketched world that makes ample use
of Norse mythology and reaches fantastic
boss battles later in October telltale
games completed the narrative arc of
tales from the borderlands although the
series's episodes ranged from fant stick
tube just fine the finale brought
everything full circle wrapping up
characters journeys in satisfying ways
and making us care about a ragged group
of misfits speaking of misfits the new
assassin's creed syndicate centers are
not one but two assassins in the alleys
of london during the industrial
revolution with a believable open-world
a plethora of side missions to pursue
and two of our favorite protagonists in
the perennial series Jacob and Evie may
be the newest in a long line of leading
assassins but their enduring
relationship and dynamic personalities
make them some of the better characters
in the long-running series but when all
said and done it was halo 5 guardians
that captivated us with fine-tuned plan
movement and level design making spot
and abilities fluid and dynamic the
co-operative campaign is also compelling
with eight super soldiers to choose from
as for the multiplayer this is halo near
its peak maps are balanced and differing
elevations make battles as vertical as
they are expansive halo 5 also ditches
the call of duty inspired loadout system
of halo 4 opting instead to return to
the classic halo formula weapon pickups
and all but it's a new war zone
multiplayer map that truly sets
guardians apart drawing clear
inspiration from MOBAs warzone pets two
teams against each other on massive
battlefields and includes a variety of
mini bosses to change up the player
versus player skirmishes with each team
racing to 1000 points and the new
requisition system fueling weapon and
vehicle possibilities war zone is the
mode that kept us playing despite a slew
of excellent for releases it not only
makes halo 5 worth returning too often
but clears a promising path for
innovation in the shooter genre
you